hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
over the course of a typical video game
you will slay countless enemies
don't worry though we can hide behind
the fact that it's a video game
to disguise our own sociopathic
tendencies by the time we reach the
final boss we are so driven that we will
take them down by any means necessary on
a few special occasions we go to X
Dreams and kill the main antagonist in
ways that are so over-the-top they need
to be put in list form on a YouTube
video so here are 7 times overkill was
underrated oh and just in case you
haven't guessed already spoilers
incoming for the following games
none of which come after 2014 Deadpool
has always been a fourth-wall breaking
oddball and that transferred orbited
video games perfectly just ask Wolverine
all the time to wake up right stubby
fine
that's for all the carbons that's for
never calling just to say huh that's
because I get aroused but it's my people
that's for other furry [ __ ] of the
world in the 2013 Deadpool video game
the Merc with the mouth went up against
sinister a super villain with superhuman
strength telekinesis conclusive energy
projections and telepathy to name a few
skills on his resume during the final
battle Deadpool and the x-men take on
multiple Sinister's until they find and
identify the real sinister and then this
happens
an uppercut to the grind followed by a
time-traveling dog riding a sentinel
foot to stomp out victory I'd explain
but the randomness is better if I don't
oh did you see how the squishy bits of
life Oh an extra kudos for the Star Wars
poster finish nicely roll credits
we're done here the evil within is a
daunting jump scare filled punt wetting
survival horror thrill ride it's
basically every horror film you can
imagine rolled into one starting with a
policeman called to a mental hospital
what could go wrong by the end of the
story we are forced to take down some
weird and wonderful enemies which all
seem to be guarding of rain well it
turns out that this was all a dream or
rather a nightmare so how do we defeat
this final boss the brain the enemies
were guarding actually belongs to ruvik
who's been slowly feeding us nightmare
your
not anymore darling
one boot versus one brain that's one way
to get to the bottom of this that was an
attempt and lobotomy joke didn't go well
move on did you ever play Sleeping Dogs
what a game that was playing as an
undercover cop taking down organized
crime the final battle has you facing
big smile Lee I'm unsure if that's his
real name or a nickname by the way with
our character facing certain death Lee
has a gun to our head but he makes the
typical bad guy era of talking instead
of shooting dispute can only end in a
combo face-off
yeah
said all you got
[Music]
Wei Shen prevails and we're certain to
arrest him like the good cop we are but
then a prompt pops up on screen throw
big smiley into the ice chipper you
don't have to tell me twice what the
heck did we just witness this is why
people don't trust the Popo just causes
kept us enthralled with explosions and
questionable physics since 2006
Rico's mission is to relieve dictators
from their power but he doesn't tend to
end their days with a simple bullet in
san espera Tirico takes down mendoza in
what appears to be a one-on-one duel
aboard an aeroplane but then things take
a change in direction when the dictator
makes a break for it
see what happens when you make me angry
what a mess Rico reappeared in Just
Cause 2 but this time the dictator he
needs to take down is aboard an atomic
submarine after fighting through troves
of enemies he finally faces baby panty
hey I don't make these names up honestly
these are legit I have news for you I
have four nuclear missiles ready to blow
so if a Chinese Japanese or Russians try
to screw me well they're in for a nasty
surprise
and the fourth what do you think it is
of course pointed at the very wart on
the face of the earth America anyway
once Rico tracks down panty they somehow
make their way onto nuclear missiles for
the final fight
I told you I am invincible I have him
tear off your skin and hold you to a
tree your suffering will be not stopped
looks like you'll be spending some time
with your beloved oil after all after a
little scuffle Rico jumps off just in
time to see the dictator belong to
pieces over an oil field so Rico freed
the country from oppression but then
nuked it's only way to prosper nicely
done sir
the spoils of our little revolution that
fossil sludge would have started the
mother of our Wars Sniper Elite brought
us one of the greatest video game
mechanics of all time slow-motion x-ray
bullet damage playing as a sniper during
the Second World War we've seen some
nasty sights in order to rid the world
of a Nazi regime in fact since 2001
we've been cracking skulls popping lungs
and taking down Hitler in many ways but
the most satisfying of other methods is
the sacred nut shut
[Applause]
we rarely do this to identify if it's
Hitler on one of his look-alikes because
supposedly Hitler only had one plum
downstairs Wow
that's nuts I can't have a list of epic
ways to kill a final boss without modern
warfare 2 this was arguably the greatest
time to be a Call of Duty player with
both the campaign and the multiplayer
being absolute perfection in my eyes the
campaign in particular was a masterpiece
and the final battle lived up to
expectations after being double-crossed
by commanding officer Shepard we fill
the boots of salt McTavish attempting to
track down Shepard who immediately does
this so all things didn't really go to
plan and a few minutes later we'll be
dead
unless
saved at a last second by captain price
sub watches on as Shepard literally gets
away with murder but then the brilliance
begins
[Music]
[Music]
pulling a knife out of his own gut and
straight-up launching it into Shepards
eye socket now that's the ultimate way
to defeat an end boss oh and don't worry
too much about soap and price they are
okay well for now at least so there you
go there's seven extreme ways to take
down a boss I know there are so many
more so please let me know which bosses
you've killed in epic or grotesque ways
and I'll make a follow-up video
showcasing those moments oh one last
thing
we now have a discord so if you'd like
to join please do so the details are
below we're looking to build a community
but I'll tell you more about that if you
choose to join thanks for your time I'm
Adam from Playstation grenade it's been
a pleasure I'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]